big thank you to surf shark VPN for
sponsoring this video
today's topic you could always count on
the the media to just Cape for there's
two separate incidents but I feel like
it's the same umbrella on one hand you
have Amber Heard who has audio that's
come out that clearly indicates that she
is somebody who was only got Gayle King
who had a misstep during an interview
with Lisa Leslie and now everyone's mad
at snoop because of he made ports Gayle
if you didn't see basically he mocked
her looks he made some comments about
her looking like a dog and then after
working out where he Fay I'm not maybe
what he said and then afterwards he said
you better watch what you say we gonna
get you
okay now the whole media uproar here's
my problem with this whole situation
you know because everyone's now come to
her support everyone has come together
support I stand with Gayle everyone's
posting that all the media outlets you
got even like the former Deputy Minister
from Obama saying the Suzanne rice like
everybody's coming to the defense of
Gayle King there's a Forbes article it
says here's what Gayle King was 100%
right to ask about Kobe Bryant's legacy
and Snoop Dogg was wrong really is this
issue black and white to you do you
think that Gayle was 100% right about
what she said hmm because even Gayle
herself has admitted that that looked
wrong yes she's even Gayle herself has
apologized for how things came out even
Gayle herself says we should demand an
apology from CBS and so somewhere in
there somebody is messed up
so what no not to the media everything
is snoops fault now here's the thing I
think this issue is nuanced I think you
can levy criticism at Gail when she
agrees with without having to retina
looks like everybody ignored what people
were saying just to talk about Snoop
Dogg's response and I'm like when a
Snoop Dogg's response ever been this
important so let me get this right you
got one person who makes it available
right in a cellphone video very
spur-of-the-moment you guys pick it up
and you hash tag everything and
everyone's writing articles
everyone's on top of it they ignore the
core issue and that's all they want to
talk about but when you have Amber Heard
who's showing up to the Oscars or
Grammys what was it this weekend the
Oscars
Yeah right she's showing up no problem
nobody's asking for no questions
nobody's talking about the fact that she
beat up a man for so long unless she has
a history of doing this stuff nobody
picks up on it it's not even so much
that they didn't they didn't ask didn't
show her like no they did some of them
showed her but these other people just
she's skipped over it it's not that
they're ignoring her bro That's not me
true because they posted articles about
how she looked at the Oscars there's
articles about that a myth the Johnny
Depp drama and that was just drama Amber
Heard in dogs in the PDA would be listen
that's it man this is if you needed any
more indication that the media is so
literally driven just look at this look
at these two stories look at how they're
being covered see did I like big thank
you to surf shark VPN for sponsoring
this video a VPN as a privacy protection
tool that guarantees online safety so
that no one can see your passwords your
private messages or steal any of your
photos videos or any other private
information I'm a big fan of VPNs
honestly when I'm traveling and when I
want to buy flights for cheap
I used it recently because I'm going to
Brazil and when you're let's say looking
for flights I had a friend of mine who's
booking from Sao Paulo
friend is already down there just
because their IP address is situated in
Brazil they were shown a price on a
ticket far higher than what I had
so once we use surf shark just basically
bass the IP address we both got the same
price and then from there we get to
travel for cheap and I use this pretty
much always when I travel another thing
is just content I want to watch TV shows
when I want to watch them and based off
where you live you may know how to have
access to certain streaming services and
so with surf sharks I can just mask my
IP address and from there I get access
so use my code to get 83 percent off
plus one extra month for free surf shark
offers a 30 day money back guarantee so
there's no risk so try it out for
yourself link is in the description
below I think the problem is now we're
deflecting from the conversation at hand
which is about the journalistic
integrity of CBS and Gale herself in
order to talk about a minority of people
who show this kind of sentiment I think
that was the point let's defuse the
situation talk about something else
it's a straw man because here you have a
straw man is when you
make an argument against the point that
the other person never made people are
having this conversation as if everyone
agrees with Snoop Dog anybody who
disagrees with Gail is with Snoop Dog
that's not the reality plenty of people
or actually disagree and just with
Gail's comment so when you only address
that part of it you are ignoring the
voice of the people that echoes
frustration snoopeh has that same
sentiment but he echoed it in a way
that's absolutely incorrect so you're
not getting to the root of the problem
which is a lot of black people feel like
our heroes are role models every time
something happens to them their legacies
have to be tarnished and sometimes it's
justifiable but in other cases were like
what's the point of this scene Everland
that documentary was half hazard and
Oprah had these so-called accusers on
the show despite their stories being
shoddy and I'm like what is the point of
this especially how long after he bagged
what is the point of this then you have
the same instance with Kobe bright where
it's a case from 17 years ago very
shoddy case right basically she did what
CBS did to her she went there on one
side on only one side she went with that
question to Leslie with only one side
yeah CBS Wendy Wendy Wendy in the air at
that interview they just aired one side
I would have been fine with Gail
presenting these questions to Lisa in
the interview had she presented the
entire case it bothered me because she's
like Lisa what do you think about Kobe's
let you see considering that that's not
how I view him I don't think he would do
that and she's like yeah but Lisa you
wouldn't see any so I'm like we did
why'd you ask the question right if
you're gonna just invalidate what she
thinks because she's a friend why did
you ask a question had she agreed me
like yeah Kobe is like that you would
have put it into like yeah great job
your opinion matters but the moment she
disagrees with you yet your opinions
invalid how does that make sense that
means you only went in there seeking one
answer at all you know even when you
watch the clip in its entirety it's like
you got a present at all if you're gonna
bring up this stuff give it the new ones
that deserves you want to believe that
this issues nuanced you want us to see
it nuances situation yeah right you say
oh look at the entirety of the situation
if you look at the entirety of the clip
I'm like that's great why don't you do
the same thing with this case that's
what we're asking ourselves when you
present things from one thing of course
we're gonna feel like you have a
narrative because you're omitting a
whole bunch of facts that are relevant
to how people are going to perceive the
case okay so it makes me judge you a
certain type of way but the thing that
happened is that they like like the the
media like they like trains they like to
jump under BAM
oh sure wagon depends which one not it
depends which one does if the trains
gonna ride over Johnny Depp
but if there's a woman involved so hop
the choo-choo train that's right
next station Amber Heard you heard is
gonna get off and that's pretty much it
so what's the rule for the media team
jump on a bandwagon it's a liberal
bandwagon anything that conforms to
their ideology women can never be bad
men always are the bad ones women are
always good to me just the media so
disingenuous with this stuff there is no
nuance to the discussion and it's like
I'm not buying it I don't stand with
Gail why are we diverting from the real
discussion at hand in terms of
journalistic integrity just so you guys
can see oh my God look at us we're gonna
defend a woman yo get out of here with
that that's corny so anyways that's all
I want to say about this I just I was
just really bothered by how this
discussion was happening we're talking
about a doob in a bathrobe who had a
funky looking head wrap on his head
yelling some random stuff that's where
the discussion is now on a side note oh
geez
rappers stop taking your videos like
this okay why am i seeing your ceiling
wise 90% of my screen your ceiling like
I don't understand if you had a shame to
leave behind you but a lot of you guys
just got wife's it's weird your framing
is off like I know you guys have had
technology long enough to figure this
[ __ ] out it's confusing it's more game
it's like why to be shoot like that
you're aiming is for you shoot like this
same thing why hold it
it's just wag you don't hold your phone
and my really dog what is your
explanation it swag is I think you know
shoot like this shoot like this you know
I mean sideways
[Music]
well Gail recognizes that it was not
really her because she okay and the
point in the viewpoint of Gail what was
the whole interview that's gonna be air
or was gonna be aired the real thing
that happened there's a whole lot more
they made me spend two hours three hours
there maybe two hours there there's
gonna be cut to 45 minutes right so if
in their head all of that that two hours
they really just go into a section and
they just and that's why I get was
pissed right cuz I did that two hours
it's we do and I talk to that girl you
took only this portion you blew it out
and that's the EU made the whole the
whole thing the whole conversation about
that I understand someone like you said
someone I understand the point of view
but she has been shady Oh has been
cheating in the past which brings to the
next point that you know everything is
not black and white you know it doesn't
matter if it's not because you've been
shady in the past that you always shitty
or all shitty but if we if we talk about
the black the black man issue thing
they've been wrong and I get that we can
disagree without calling names that goes
for the whole internet in the whole you
can't people in nowadays is like you
can't disagree with someone without
insulting their character you can't
that's what I see something and uh in
the the reaction to someone that is not
that is not agreeing when someone else
is straight to 100 there's no level
today it goes straight to 100 is a week
and you have to go into name causes and
stuff like that so it's pit I don't know
why it is like that or because people
are comfortable behind your screens or
stuff like that and I understand what
happened on both sides but yeah